amoro jean baptiste asks is there any is
there anything scientific to the
different reaction of superman cells to
red sun versus yellow sun ooh good
question well you never answered the
superman question superman cells are
they effective oh after the previous
break yeah yeah well good morning being
really scientific between well i have it
written down but yeah uh between the red
sun and yellow sun is that true like
would would someone potentially be able
to fly or under one sun and not under
another yeah so
we think we know stars very well at this
point is one of the triumphs of 20th
century modern astrophysics how stars
are born how they live out their lives
how they die what their properties are
yeah their friends are what their
favorite well literally they're well
figuratively stars have friends they're
born in clusters
and clusters of a few 10 you know
clutches are pairs yeah they're binary
stars triple stars quadruple stars
quintuple stars stars that have hundreds
of star systems they have hundreds of
stars thousands of stars hundreds of
thousands of wow so their cousins uncles
aunts all of these except they're all
born at the same time so they're
simultaneous in their generation here's
the thing
we know the difference between a yellow
star and a red star
you know one the yellow stars and is it
ten percent
the yellow star is hotter than the red
star
period and it gives off a little more
white light okay a little more yellow
light than does the red star yeah it's
just light so if it's light that gave
superman his powers
then
and this and if it's red light that took
him away yeah then all you need to do is
shine red light on superman and he'd be
a pile of a crying crying mess you know
lex luthor really can hear you so you
really shouldn't be saying things like
that
so it's not so you don't even need
kryptonite you just need a flashlight we
have fully characterized the light
emanating from stars and a red star if
superman did not have powers on krypton
but he has power on on the krypton
system yeah and he has powers on the
earth sun system
then we we would have had him figured
out long ago so but even if his skin is
like a solar battle battery that absorbs
the energy like uh oh yeah so if uh the
yellow sun absorbs higher and emits a
yellow sun emits higher energy light
than does a red sun and he could be
absorbing it and then red light wouldn't
ruin him right away he could be except
we know exactly how much energy his skin
can absorb and it's infinite no it's
can't be any more than the light hitting
him right and there's most of the sun's
light is not hitting it it's hitting the
ground it's hitting your butt on a beach
he might slide his butt first towards
the sun until he's so powerful he comes
and puts in that dull ability
i wish now to be more realistic superman
flew butt first towards my son i assure
you superman needs much more many more
solar panels than what
his skin clad
with such material could bring him given
the powers that he exhibits so it's some
mystical thing that is not real even
though magic's really the only thing
that can hurt him but i understand what
you mean also did you know i was in a
superman comic uh no but i believe it oh
wait i think i did know that yeah it was
action comics 140 or 142 just a few
months ago back in uh and i would chill
and superman came to visit me at the
hayden and did you tell him all these
terrible things and you're like i don't
think your skin's as powerful as you
think it is no you just tease so i
praised him for all the good work he's
done in gotham because you mean
metropolis i'm so sorry am i mixing
batman no sorry metropolis yes it's
almost as if those worlds aren't real to
you
so yeah i mean i've been lifelong
residents of metropolitan metropolis and
so he wanted some help finding krypton
on the sky and so i pointed out star
that you think would be
the planet that and we showed it to him
in the planetarium dome so it was kind
of cool that's awesome yeah
you